ed orgeron and ellis you've decided
middle of october let's part ways at the
end of the year this story is banana
very weird and
does the
list of coaches to fill that slot start
with jimbo fisher at texas a m
joining us right here uh who he wrote
about this very subject on the athletic
joining us also from fox sports is our
friend bruce feldman once again how are
you bruce i'm doing well rich good to be
on with you sorry i'm gonna be i could
have been in the studio since tomorrow
to meet larry david okay well i'll i'll
give you a little bit more heads up next
time how about that um
so let's get into this uh where did this
come from with uh at orgeron and lsu we
we know obviously the losing but is
there something else behind the scenes
that we're missing where this takes oh i
think the biggest thing honestly is he
didn't win enough it's the ad who who is
there now scott woodward is a guy who
loves to make flashy hires scott wood's
not the adu hired lsu he took over right
before the national title
season in 2019
i think what really hurt oger on as much
as anything was
he made some bad coordinator hires he
made some really good ones to help him
win the national title and then the ones
after that didn't work out beau fellini
as the defensive coordinator last year
was a disastrous hire and then he was on
a hot seat and he went with
two younger uh first-time play callers
who have done an okay job but there's
been some growing pains and ozeron did
not have much margin for error national
title or not
uh a year ago he did not have much
margin for error and i think that has
cost them
and so
you know i think it i think it's really
as simple as that he just did not uh did
not win enough in the last 18 months
after winning the national title okay so
then now what i mean and why why why is
he sticking around the rest of the
season they just figured it's better if
he agrees to stick around then it's
better than just putting an interim in
there or you know i mean yeah i think
remember he's getting 17 million dollars
to walk away so this is a school this
was his dream school growing up he
obviously
is a native of louisiana and i couldn't
tell i couldn't tell okay i know sounds
like he's from brooklyn right yeah
exactly right he ended up you know
feeling like okay i want to still coach
my team and and ride this out and so
we'll we'll see where it goes from there
but i think at this point
you know this was the solution for that
they had worked out over the last week
or so that he would stay on to finish
out the year i'm not sure what an
interim would have would have done for
them i mean at one point i remember
having a conversation with him what and
this is before they beat florida last
weekend was like hey what happens if you
go on a little roll do you think that
gets you
you know do you think that gets you off
the hot seat and he was like no they
want to go in a different direction
he kind of was kind of he knew
what was going on
um you know before obviously everything
came out sunday you know whether they
beat florida which they did and even if
they beat ole miss even if they somehow
were to knock off alabama the leadership
at lsu had already decided
we want a new guy in there so that's the
direction okay and so uh
you know i i read your story i'll i
don't want to cannibalize it you do what
you wish to share whatever you or
whatever you wish
uh on the athletic i saw a photograph of
jimbo fisher on twitter which i'll be
honest led me to also click on it like
really texas a m's jimbo fisher that's
the guy that they're going to try and
target
rich keep in mind the guy who who hired
jimbo fisher away from from florida
state
is scott woodward when he was the a.d
there so he has a relationship
he is he was also the guy who got chris
peterson to leave boise to go to
washington when he was the ada at
washington so he has a track record i
mean even his his women's basketball
coach now kim mulkey one national title
is a baylor he got he signed her so i
think
you know from what i my reporting is
he's already had a conversation with
jimbo fisher
jim fisher sounds like he's you know not
going to make this jump at this point he
has no buyout though at a m he could
leave without penalty it's just you know
he's already got four years in at texas
a m trying to build a foundation there
i'm not sure you know how why he would
make the move to lsu in that case i was
told by another source close to scott
woodward that
he was going to take a big swing and see
if dabo sweeney had an andrews that was
when he only has a 3 million dollar
buyout but he's in the acc where there's
no alabama and there's no kirby smart
and georgia recruiting like they are
so when you're in clemson you're
dominant you know built to dominate
there now they're having a down year but
still i'd be surprised if he was tempted
to leave i understand scott ward would
really
uh scott woodward
you know wants big hot big name hires i
know the new president at lsu really
likes james franklin at penn state he
coached in the sec did a terrific job
at vanderbilt vanderbilt used to be
awful then he got there and got him in
the top 25 a couple seasons then he left
and vanderbilt went back to being awful
um i don't know if james franklin would
would be tempted to leave
uh leave penn state for
lsu i don't know if you'd be tempted to
leave penn state for usc but he's
definitely got some interest in then the
name that we reported this weekend mel
tucker he's at your rival school
michigan state done a really nice job
there
a lot of key people at lsu are very
enamored with him untold you know so
would he make that move would he be a
big enough you know it's a little bit of
a gamble because this is the first year
in three years as a head coach that mel
tucker's gonna have a winning season
people are really impressed with him but
you know is that is that a big enough
name for them i don't know we'll see how
this plays out well i mean uh michigan
state has sent a head coach to lsu
before right i mean that that's happened
kind of yeah it kind of worked out
worked out to be a good hire for that
one
i'm referring to nick saban um and
so yeah i mean i have no problem if mel
tucker wants to take that job i'll be
very happy if that happens i mean he's
getting him out of the state right now
you want him no doubt no no doubt about
that so that's a fascinating story that
uh will be playing out with usc also in
the market which one's a better job
which one would you take
uh i live in los angeles i like the
weather out here yeah i'm asking the
wrong guy right
there's no humidity here i know there's
humidity in baton rouge
the reason why i think if you're james
franklin if you were if you feel like
you're you would you're open to leaving
penn state
you know
there's no nick saban in alabama in the
pac-12 south right i mean and even if
you're even if you get past that part of
it look what kirby smart has a mass
talent-wise with all these five stars
he's in the same conference he's not in
the same division but you're still gonna
have to go through that to win a
conference title
uh you know what the state of the pac-12
is right now i mean the pac-12 south is
is is mush at this point and so
i don't know i mean to me that's the
part where it's just like
if if you can convince the coaches
whoever you're trying to woo at
if you're usc whether it's luke fickle
from cincinnati or james franklin
you know at penn state i think the big s
one of the big selling points is you
know the head coach is going to get paid
in a big way
will they convince them that their
support staff and their assistants will
will get paid where they don't feel like
the cost of living is a dramatic
difference from the college towns those
those coaches are in now and what their
what how that plays out i think that's
the biggest selling point usc has to
convince whoever they try to land bruce
feldman college football insider from
the athletic and fox sports few minutes
left with him here on the rich eisen
show washington state's now suddenly got
an opening huh what yeah that thing has
been a fiasco um for
you know a couple of months now in terms
of the situation nick rolovich
the relationship had just withered away
to nothing with he and his bosses
so now what's tricky there is
basically it's not just roloff it's
rollerblades and four of his assistants
and this isn't like alabama or some of
these other places we have like 20
analysts that you can plug in they got
to find other coaches who are you know
basically on the street who are
available who would jump in to finish
the second half of the season and be
vaccinated right i mean again for those
who may not know uh rolovich refused to
get vaccinated
and was given what an ultimatum to to
get the shot and he refused and they
obliged him with the ability to go get
the you know be unvaccinated elsewhere
correct that's that's what happened
yeah in a nutshell and then you know now
we'll see what they do on their in their
coaching search you know
later on because like i said right now i
talked to the aed last night and they
just said you know they had some
contingency plans but now to line up
people because it's not just role of it
rolovich is a hands-on offensive coach
it's his offensive coordinator also was
was let go and his offensive line coach
so and runs a run and shoot it's not
like you're going to find a bunch of
coaches who are versed in that offense
who are out there you know so they're
not you know mouse davis is 89 years old
i don't know if mouse davis is a guy
who's gonna
they're gonna call up and say hey you
know you feel like you're up to coaching
finishing the college football season
for us i mean it's a really
awkward and unique dynamic that they
have that those players who've been
through a lot there they've had a couple
of players
you know in their careers there
pass away tragically uh they've been
through coaching change remember mike
leach
was there and he's only you know he's
only been gone for a year and a half
so it's just a lot of
it's just a lot of like uh uncertainty
and and tumultuous stuff that those
players have dealt with and now this is
the latest turn on them
uh last one for you um the quarterback
switch in oklahoma caleb williams what
what's spencer rattler gonna do he is he
have any choices i mean the kid
obviously was a few you know six weeks
ago we were talking about you know uh
suck for spencer spencer in the nfl for
the draft and now
he has been replaced and it looks like
oklahoma has been born anew
in their chance to win a championship
what's going on there it is a crazy plot
to us uh rich like in the summer he was
out here for the elite 11 camp where all
the as a counselor and he was like ari
gold doing nil deals left and right and
then
um
you know people there was a lot of hype
around him he struggled
and caleb williams who has a lot of a
lot of buzz he was a big time recruit
that they landed out of the washington
dc area he runs better he probably has
an even stronger arm you know can make
the aaron rodgers kind of crazy off
platform throws he hit the ground
running i mean he looked great against
texas he looked really good since he's
given them a spark and unless he really
stumbles
um
you know i i'd be surprised if caleb
if
spencer rattler decides to leave ou
i'm not sure that there's going to be
enough
you know
financial sense for him to try to go
leave and become a draft pick because
you're not talking about a guy who's
who's 6'4 220 they're not going to be
like wowed by him
you know physically he runs okay but
it's not he's not a great runner i think
that he's probably going to have to
transfer someplace else he jumps in the
portal i'm sure there'll be a ton of
interest in him
um and then if it comes to that so it's
gonna be really fascinating to see what
you know what the next step is for
spencer adler assuming caleb williams
doesn't start just really struggle if he
keeps it up
you know this is lincoln riley's next
you know breakout quarterback and
honestly looking at him physically just
compared to spencer like the spencer
stuff i was a little
surprised that people were talking about
his first pick of the draft guy not
because of lincoln riley's track record
but just
i don't know there was some a little bit
of question marks you know our buddy dj
dale jeremiah i think could probably
fill in a lot of the gaps on that
but caleb williams has has the wow
factor physically and like wouldn't
shock me if he was a first pick of the
draft guy a couple of years from now
though well i mean and in that regard
about the difference physically about
wow factor and not
um just to finish up for a moment for me
here a lot of my friends and colleagues
and fellow alums
at michigan were just ecstatic about the
start of the wolverines this year and
where there are and how well-positioned
they are heading into this game coming
off a buy against northwestern before
the gauntlet of the states michigan penn
and ohio come their way
um
jj mccarthy we're wondering why he keeps
popping up in the game you know because
cade mcnamara has that moxie factor from
the old days that i think jim
uh uh loves and he made only one mistake
against nebraska that's literally one of
the only mistakes he's ever made since
getting the starting role at michigan
like what what's the quarterback
scenario there that you're hearing about
i think he's trying to make sure he has
another guy ready you know i think
obviously
jj has a lot of physical tools i mean
bigger arm i think there's there's a lot
of intrigue with what he can do i think
you want to get him ready i uh honestly
rich i also think you want to make sure
he's engaged and not thinking i don't
want to sit here for a while and not
think i have a chance to play
and i think this is you know
quarterbacks in 2021 where
guys aren't going to be a lot of aren't
going to be that patient and so i think
you you need to make sure he's still
engaged because
he feels like he's the future of the
program whether he's the future
you know if things don't go great
against one of those opponents and they
struggle does he start the second half i
don't know because as they've run the
heck out of the football obviously
and if
you know they've been able to be more
physical than a lot of teams they played
to this point will that work against
michigan state penn state and ohio state
we'll see you know i i think that this
at least
you know to me
it's like just hey we got to get the
other guy ready just in case and i think
that's what what they've tried to be
very judicious in his reps and in his
game time all right as we matriculate
our way to november um look for my call
bruce we'll we'll revisit and uh see how
the top 10 gets reconfigured between now
and our next chat thanks for the call
sounds good always pleasure right back
at you at bruce feldman cfb i follow him
on twitter you should as well from the
athletic and fox sports
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here